mcdonald had a farm with a certain
number of orange trees he had to cut
down five trees to control the insects
each of the remaining trees produced 210
oranges producing a total harvest of 41
790 oranges how many trees did
mcdonald's farm have initially
so let's let t
equal what they're asking us for so this
is the number
of trees
trees initially
initially
so he starts off with tea trees but then
they tell us that he has to cut down he
has to cut down five trees to control
the insects so how many trees would he
have after that well he started with t
and he had to cut down five so he's
going to have t minus five trees now
now they tell us
they tell us that each of the remaining
trees each of the remaining trees and we
know they're t minus five remaining
trees produced 210 oranges so each of
these t minus five trees are going to
produce 210 oranges so this is the
number of oranges the t minus five trees
are going to produce this is the number
of trees times the oranges per tree so
this is the total number of oranges
produced after cutting the five trees
and then they tell us
they tell us that this ends up being a
total harvest a total harvest of 41
and 790. so this is equal to forty one
thousand
seven hundred and ninety so we've set up
our equation now we just have to solve
for t the number of trees that mcdonald
initially had
so the first thing i would do here is
while i'm multiplying
this expression by 210 well why don't i
just divide both sides of this by 210.
there's many ways that you could do this
you could distribute the 210 and and and
go to another direction actually i will
do it both ways just to show that you
could do it both ways so the first way
i'm going to divide both sides by 210
210
the left hand side simplifies to t
minus 5
t minus 5. the right hand side let's see
what is four thousand
do some long division here do it on the
side so four thousand one hundred forty
one thousand seven hundred and ninety
divided by
two hundred and ten
let's see 210 does not go into four does
not go into 41 it goes into 417
one time because two times would be 420.
one time one times 210 is 210
you subtract you get 207
and then you bring down the nine how
many times does 210 go into
2079 it looks like it would go into it
not quite 10 times looks like it would
go into it nine times
nine times two hundred and ten is going
to be let's see nine times zero is zero
nine times one is nine nine times two is
eighteen
and then we subtract again
see nine minus zero is nine
see we can we have to regroup from the
thousands place so let's take a thousand
from there
let's give
let's give that thousand to the hundreds
place so it becomes ten hundreds but
then we have to take a hundred from the
hundreds place so this becomes nine and
give it to the tens place so this
becomes 17 tens or 170. so 17 minus nine
is eight
nine minus eight is one and so we get
one
189
and now we can bring down another
zero
bring down another zero
it's a little off-center right now and
we already see that 210 goes into
1899 times
9 times 210 is 1890
and we subtract we have no remainder so
what we get on the right hand side is
199
100
and
and now we just have to add five to both
sides remember whatever we have to do to
one side we have to do to the other
otherwise the equality wouldn't be equal
anymore they were equal before adding
five so if you want them to still be
equal you have to do the same thing to
both sides so the left-hand side becomes
t
the t in that
purple color
becomes t
and the right hand side becomes 204
so he started off with 204 trees now i
told you there's multiple ways to do
this you could have instead of dividing
both sides by 210 you could have decided
to decide to distribute the 210 and then
you would have ended up with let me do
another alternate way of doing it 210
times t
times t
minus 5 times 210
minus 210 times 5
210 actually let me just multiply it out
so we save some space 5 times 210 is
1050 minus 1050 is equal to
41
790 and then you could add 1050 to both
sides
and so we do that 1050
to both sides
1050 not 150
1050 to both sides
the left hand side you're just going to
be left with
210 t
while the right hand side you're going
to be left with let's see you're going
to be 0 plus 0 is 0
9 plus 5 is 14
1 plus 7 is 8
42
840 and now you can divide both sides by
210
you could divide both sides by 210
and now we know where this is going to
go i could do the long division again
t is going to be equal to 42 840 divided
by 210 which is equal to
204.